très capable de se passer de sexe
pendant un mois bon maxime on sait que
certains veulent voir si tout le monde
autour de la table et aussi prisonnier
de ses addictions tu vois par exemple
benjamin castaldi les addicts au mariage
voilà qui serait capable d'arrêter de
fumer et de le faire tout de suite
voilà cliquez dans les pâtures qui
fument l'hôtel avait dit oui j'ai suivi
des st moritz les machines très long
mars et pas desservi ne sais pas si ça
c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas l'un des
leviers pour vous moi j'ai arrêté de
jouer en masse y remercie pour votre
fille j'étais remercier al mabry ce
qu'elle voulait se joue je lui ai
demandé ce qu'elle voyait comme cadeau
un vide sur le cadeau que je veux c'est
une tare est de fumée l'un des plus
beaux paquets tzigane j'ai coupé en deux
genres est capable de se passer de sexe
pendant un mois bon maximum c'est que ça
fait vingt mois quoi tu fais deux fois
par semaine mais je pourrais m'en passer
devant moi
where pauvres sont tu fais pas de voix
par ce même si celles ci sont maria
attendait les inerties mairie avec ton
mari
avec vous ils vous pourriez moi c'est
beaucoup parce que à fatou me dit moi je
pourrais m'en passer dit vous maintenant
possible parce que je sais que votre
fiancée et 1,30 en plus que vous êtes à
26,26 jusqu'au bout mais pourquoi vous
dites toujours personnelle espalux est
un personnage et c'est dans ce prix là
demain
un possible aaa
impossible moi je peux de quoi moi je
peux c4 sait que sa dévouée sans témoin
[Rires]
sa meringue récifs quoi c'est à devenir
un petit bagarreur moi non je mens
possible c'est l'argent des mythos bah
oui c'est vrai voilà je pense parce
qu'il est graphiquement le fais moi on a
envie donc une fois confié à moi on peut
tenir après doit regarder il ya des mecs
qui sont 26 juin il est tellement accro
à son conjoint qui n'auraient pourrait
pas s'en passer pendant une semaine vous
aussi vous pouvez pas vous passer de
fatou bâ elle me manque quelques mois
quelques heures ça va mais deux ou trois
jours c'est impossible a ouais c'est
vrai que savoir ce qu'elle fait et ça le
faire indique de la tentation ouest et
bouées et ça c'est important dans les
abords je voudrais avons le savoir soit
parce que c'est important vous le disiez
maintenant qui pourrait se passer
complètement de salaire
[Rires]
mais est ce qu'on parle de tpm chose que
oui parce que du coup c'est plus un
défraiement qu'un salon
[Applaudissements]
et ben voilà on l'a déféré rappelé
[Rires]
[Musique]